hey what's going on everybody
i am dave rubin and this is the reuben
report direct message for february 25th
2021 before we do anything else i
quickly want to remind you
that you can get 30 off your annual
blaze subscription just go to
blazetv.com
and that ends uh tomorrow night
so get to it if you want to save 30
bucks off the yearly subscription
at blazetv.com uh we're doing a q a
today i am going to
cover one story because there was one
story that i saw this morning
that was so bananas so bonkers
so absolutely ridiculous and yet so
painfully real that i felt i had to do
it
in addition to doing uh the q a uh
we could try to maybe fit in one or two
last second question
questions if you want to submit right
now at rubinreport.locals.com although
we got a gajillion of them so i can't
make
any promises and oh and by the way
uh you know i mentioned yesterday that
my team that we were
literally hysterically laughing like
like
tears rolling down our face hysterically
laughing before the show began i was
actually crying when the show
started i had like tears in my eyes
because of this video that somebody sent
me i decided not to post it publicly
anywhere because the canceled people i
just didn't want to deal with the
headache i've got a lot going on
not that anyone can cancel me on my own
boss and the chances that i walk into
the room and say dave we're gonna have
to have a sit down and
dave we're gonna have to get rid of you
like it's probably not gonna happen i
just didn't want to deal with the
headache anyway i did post
the video for subscribers only at
rubinreport.locals.com all right we're
going to get to about
20 of your questions before we do that
real quick guys i want to talk to you
about bonner private wine i've got the
wine bottle right here you know i like
wine
you know next time you grill up a couple
steaks guys pop open
a bottle of extreme altitude malbec wine
it comes from these remote vineyards in
argentina
located up at about 9000 feet that's
pretty high
when these vintners aren't making wine
they're herding cattle so they know meat
they know barbecue and that's what these
malbecs are
for as soon as you open the bottle
you're going to experience delicious
notes of blackberry leather smoke and a
little dark cherry
you're also going to get less sugar less
chemicals and additives and 10 times
more
resveratrol which is a powerful
longevity booster there used to be a
rumor
that um what's her name who's the lady
on the on the view
uh who started the view the old lady
what the hell was her name
barbara walters there used to be a rumor
that barbara walters
uh bathed in resveratrol i don't know if
it's true uh the guys over at
freethinkerwine.com just got a special
shipment of these wines in
they've got one malbec from the third
highest vineyard in the world at about
eight thousand nine hundred fifty feet
visit freethinkerwine.com today
and you'll get fifty percent off the
line and 50 off shipping
uh this was just a small batch and it's
gonna go fast visit
freethinkerwine.com that's
freethinkerwine.com
and now back to me freethinkerwine.com
there you go all right so i want to do
one story i just cannot believe this and
yet it's so obviously real that it's
like
just the perfect story for our whacked
out world that we're living in
uh so let's throw these images up right
now there is a high school
in washington that is having their br
banned practices in small
i guess they're calling them tents
although i can't really call that a tent
it seems like some sort of green
fabric evil coffin that's what i'd
rather call it they call it a tent
i call it a green evil fabric coffin
this is a real picture
these are not photoshopped you can see
the students in band class
in these tiny things that the
ventilation doesn't look great i don't
know how they're fully hearing each
other
or that how they can even get enough air
to really blow the tuba
or blow the horn are we showing the
image of the guy with the with the big
horn too i mean look at this poor kid
look at this poor kid we are making
children insane crazy
ridiculous adults with nonsensical rules
that have nothing to do with science
have decided to put high school students
in small green bags
and have them play music and if you
think that is good
if you think there's science behind that
if you think there's any reason to do
this other than to break the human
spirit
and control how people behave and what
they think then
you are a fool these are this is just
insanity
it ain't gonna stop it's just coming at
every level
the other one that i saw this morning is
that hasbro has announced that mr potato
head
won't be called mr potato head anymore
he'll just be potato head
because obviously that was offensive to
somebody or he wasn't really a man or he
is a man or being a man
you could take the mustache off then
he's mrs potato head i mean did you
watch toy story there was mr potato and
mrs
potato and you can switch all their
we live literally in the dumbest time in
in human history and there's something
to be said for that you know what i mean
like if you can keep your sense of humor
and not go completely bananas and all
that there is absolutely something to be
said oh i want to do one other thing
though is very important
before we get to all of your questions
and i will get to as many as possible
you know i've been talking a lot about
masks and we're all talking about masks
and you know originally they didn't want
us to wear masks
and then they said only sick people
should wear masks or only doctors should
wear masks
and then they said no you should wear
masks all the time and then
they said well if you know you're an
athlete while you're playing you don't
have to wear a mask but if you're
sitting on the sidelines you have to
wear a mask and the coaches have to wear
a mask
and we also had the super bowl and it
was like some people wore them some
people didn't
they would pull them down to talk to
each other the whole mask thing is just
absolutely bananas as always i believe
you should do whatever you think is
right to protect yourself
i was just in florida and guess what
there were old people a lot of old
people in florida they were at
restaurants
eating and drinking and living their
lives but the mass thing now wear two
masks wear three masks put on masks put
a face shield on wrap your head in saran
wrap dip yourself in chocolate sit out
on a field until
a bunch of ants come eat you i mean it's
just an endless cascade of anything
and i've been thinking about it so what
are we going to do about the mask what
are we going to do
is there someone we could look to who
did it right
when it came to masks and then you know
i'm a star wars guy i was thinking
you know kylo ren let's just put aside
how disastrous the the three
last movies were for just a moment kylo
ren kind of had it right about mask what
was kylo ren doing with math sometimes
he wore his mask
sometimes he didn't wear his mask it was
totally up to kylo ren it didn't really
make any sense to me
when he would put it on or what when he
would take it off and it didn't really
make sense to anyone else because if he
was wearing the mask it would be like
well we know what you look like kylo why
are you trying to scare us a little
extra
with the mask so look i got a kylo ren
mask here and my policy on masks
is sometimes i'm gonna wear the mask
okay
sometimes i'm gonna wear the mask if if
i go into a store and they demand i wear
the mask
i'm gonna put the mask on this is a very
kylo ren
sith approach to wearing masks if they
want you to wear the mask
and you feel like wearing the mask then
you should wear the mask and then
if you want to take the mask off sure
could it mess up your hair and would
that be upsetting yes
uh but if you want to take the mask off
and hang out with other people
and talk to other people and let them
see your face then then
take the mask off but again if you want
to put it on to intimidate people
and say i'm wearing a mask why aren't
you wearing a mask you see i'm better
than you i'm wearing a mask okay
look at my messed up lightsaber which
they never even explained his messed up
lightsaber uh
i think you get the point from now on
guys i took my earpiece out
also earpieces should be up to you
whatever you want to do
kylo ren style masks all right guys uh
let me tell you one more thing and then
we're going to get to all the questions
i want to talk to you about bambi guys
you know when you're running a business
hr issues can kill you wrongful
termination suits minimum wage
requirements labor regulations the list
goes on and on and hr managers salaries
aren't cheap
they can average seventy thousand
dollars a year bambi spelled b-a-m-b-e
was created specifically for small
business you can get a dedicated hr
manager craft hr policy and maintain
compliance
all for just 99 dollars a month with
bambi you can change hr from your
biggest liability to your biggest
strength
your dedicated hr manager is available
by phone
email or real-time chat from onboarding
to terminations they customize your
policies to fit your business
and help you manage your employees day
to day all for just 99 bucks a month
month to month no hidden fees cancel any
time and if you're like me i know you
don't like to start your business
because you wanted to spend time on hr
compliance
let bambi help get your free hr audit
today go to bambi.com
ruben right now to schedule your free hr
audit
that's bambi.com ruben spelled
bam to the b-e-e dot com
slash reuben all right here we go guys q
a as promised i think for this first
question
i'm feeling like wearing a mask so i'm
going to put on the mask
i feel like wearing a mask it's a free
country i'd like to wear the mask
and i'm wearing the mask so the question
from nick
i know she's working with ben shapiro
now but what are the chances we get a
gina carano
interview okay well first off gina
carano if you don't know her
uh what she's known for obviously mma
fighter she was an actress in the
mandalorian
she is a conservative or at the very
least
she is non-woke oh i guess i'm talking
about gina carano a star wars
girl while i'm wearing a kylo ren mask
it's all coming together people
that wasn't even intentional um she
posted
a a meme basically saying that those of
us who are non-woke are sort of
like the jews pre-holocaust meaning that
we're dehumanized
at every turn and when you dehumanize
other people it can lead to horrible
things there was nothing remotely
anti-semitic about what she said
there was nothing bigoted about what she
said actually she made
quite a great point i can't believe i'm
doing this in a kylo ren mask
um in any event disney got rid of her i
have cancelled my disney plus account
it's
just a little bit that any of us can do
and
she ended up now has signed a deal with
ben shapiro in the daily wire and she's
going to be doing movies where she's
going to produce an act which is exactly
how you beat cancel culture you beat it
by being brave
and building your own stuff so the
question is will we get her for an
interview i'm already in touch with her
we're talking we're going to figure it
out she just did ben's sunday special
and you can tell
and this is sort of the beautiful thing
about how people step into themselves
she you can tell it's pretty clear that
she
this is not someone who really wants to
be a public person in the fight in that
regard she wanted to be an actress she
was a fighter and then she wanted to be
an actress
but she's stepping into her moment so
yes my hope is we'll get her on for the
show i'm also talking to her about
locals and a couple other things
and we'll see but uh she deserves
nothing but our support
the people who tried to cancel her the
bad guys she ain't the bad guy
and for the people that were upset that
oh she made a holocaust reference it's
like these are the same people
who call the rest of us nazis all day
long so it's like get a clue okay you
see what i did there
very kylo ren of me i i gave the speech
with the mask
and then how am i doing over here you
know kylo sometimes
cut you know oop oh let's see
this yeah all right there we go
you know kyla would take the mask off
and sometimes his hair would be a little
crazy or his face would be a little
mushed from the mask
all right here we go guys so uh candace
says how do you feel
about michael knowles betrayal oh we're
doing a whole daily wire thing today
so uh as some of you guys may have heard
they covered this on the daily wire
backstage the other day uh i had michael
knowles over for dinner
a couple months back i think this was
probably in may something like that
and this was still when the daily wire
was in la and
you know they were all they were
thinking about moving and there had been
a lot of talk everybody was talking
about getting out of
california getting out of la could we
could we go to
tennessee could we go to texas could we
go to florida the whole thing's
happening
anyway david and i had knowles and his
wife over for dinner
about a lot of steak a lot of booze he's
a whiskey guy
uh and we talked for hours all night
about how we're gonna stay
we're gonna stay and fight and it's a
worthy cause
and we can fix this state and we can't
let the union fail and all this stuff
and hours and we're feeling good and
we're gonna team up but we're gonna stay
and fight
and then i wake up the next morning
scroll twitter and
daily wire moving to nashville knowles
is leaving so how do i feel about
knowles betrayal
he didn't know he actually didn't know
there had been some rumors of things
happening
i will work through it with knowles you
know we'll we'll get there
we'll get there um but good for good for
them for getting out of here
and and again this is what i often talk
about the foot vote
if you live in a place that is not
consistent with your views
you have options and that's a beautiful
thing in america you have less options i
mean really think about other western
countries
if you live in the uk if you live in
canada like you have less options
meaning sure you can move
you can escape a city you can escape a
town but the general laws of the country
are pretty much the same we've got that
great opportunity
that federalism has afforded us and when
i was in florida last week
as i said yesterday it really did feel
like being in another country
and in many ways that's the system that
is supposed to work that they can figure
out different things related to
education they can figure out different
things related to taxes they can figure
out
different things related to social
programs all of it
so knowles is doing well in tennessee
i'm still here
and uh we shall see antoinette asks how
long before the little one arrives are
you and david waiting
to be surprised or finding out what you
are having so we actually had a whole
bunch of questions related to our
expanding family and having a child and
everything else so many of you know and
i wrote about in the book that
we've been working on surrogacy for a
long time which is it's a
it's a whole process and and it's very
expensive and all that stuff
um so i haven't discussed this publicly
yet so i thought it would be good time
to uh
to address one question on it um our
surrogate did have a miscarriage a
couple weeks ago we found out maybe two
or three weeks ago
um obviously it sucks there's not much
more that i can say about that
so we ended up sort of back at square
one
and i will just add this um
that our surrogacy doctor our fertility
doctor i should say
um who is one one of the best in the
world i mean people fly from all over
the world to meet this guy
here in la he has told us that he has
seen more
miscarriages this year than in any other
year
of his career and there's no scientific
evidence for it meaning that the eggs
still look good our sperm was fine like
the surrogates
there's nothing wrong with the wombs and
the only thing that they can then chalk
that up to is just the general stress of
the world like that's that's not
scientifically proven
um but that's what his feeling is so uh
so we were
you know pregnant for for a certain
period of time and she did have
miscarriage so we have
actually a new egg donor um and
we've got plenty of sperm it's not we're
not we don't have a sperm shortage
around here we've got plenty of sperm
so uh so we're starting again in a
couple weeks we're using the same
surrogate who's a wonderful wonderful
girl obviously she needed a little bit
of time
uh to heal and just get right physically
and all that good stuff
and uh and we'll we'll continue we'll
continue and i will say one thing you
know i crap on california a lot
for obvious reasons the taxes the
regulation the homelessness the whole
thing
california does have the best uh
laws around surrogacy especially for
same-sex couples
in in the united states significantly
better than places like texas and
florida
so when i bash on california all the
time and i say all the great things
about some of those red states like it's
not like everything is absolutely
perfect
and that partly is one of the reasons
that we haven't bolted uh just yet but
anyway i i have no doubt that i'm gonna
get a ton of messages from you guys
with love and sympathy and all that good
stuff and i appreciate it in advance
and uh we're just we're just gonna keep
on going uh born to be free says what do
you think
trump's role should be in the future you
know i mentioned the other day someone
said to me in florida
that they would love for ron desantis
who's the current governor of florida
to run for president which i think is a
very much a possibility and would be
great on so many fronts
not only because he's been a supremely
uh
excellent executive of his state but
also because he's 46 years old i think
so get some young blood in there instead
of keep running these 70 year olds i
think he's ready to fight
and all of that good stuff so somebody
said to me desantis could be president
that could leave trump running for
governor of florida i actually think
that would be kind of interesting if
trump wants to do that
i would say the best move for trump
probably now that the second
impeachment not only failed but nobody
gave a crap
do you know anyone that gave a crap
besides blue check journalists
on twitter nobody gave a crap it was it
was a sham the entire time
i would say trump's probable best
uh best move in a public sense let's say
is that he needs to be the sort of
outside fighter for the candidates i
don't know that trump needs to run again
like could he run for president again
sure would he have more support than any
other republican you think he'll have a
little more support than mitt romney
um i think he would a little more
support than liz cheney yeah i think he
would
um but i don't know that that
necessarily is the move it's almost like
if trump can act as the
the fighter on the outside the surrogate
dealing with the media and all that
nonsense
then you could start getting a really
interesting crop of people coming up
could you then get
say your dan crenshaw's your nikki
haley's your candace owens
your ron desantis's whoever whoever it
might be some people that that we don't
even know of yet right
but having trump act as the fighter guy
through the media lens like that's
really what he loves it's what he's
great at and all of that
he could do that not have the
constraints of the political part
attached to it
and then you have some you know really
new fresh young blood get in there
and make a difference at the political
side so we'll see i think he could end
up running for
governor my guess is he won't run for
president again that just seems like
kind of too crazy but i like this sort
of outsider surrogate
thing uh ali says you mentioned a new
book
uh in the making any hints um i don't
want to say too much at the moment
i'm about halfway through with it and it
looks like it'll be released
in spring of 2022 as i told you guys the
the book
writing process well it takes a while to
write but but the publishing process is
actually quite slow
it's it's sort of um it's an archaic
business in a lot of ways
um and they are working on modernizing
it and i work with pengu
penguin random house who are like the
best of the best and i love my editor
and i love the whole team there
so i'm working on that right now and uh
i would say i don't want to i really
don't want to give too much i would say
it's going to be the next extension of
don't burn this book so you know and
don't burn this book what i tried to lay
out
were what i think are the best
principles for a free society to
flourish and for you as an individual to
flourish and of course you guys all know
i believe that
the classically liberal political lens
is the best way to do that but that
politics alone
isn't everything um so i'm going to
expand on that a bit but really try to
make this book
much more about action than ideas you
know one of the things that i'm really
interested in right now is i don't want
to just talk to people
over and over about talking everyone's
talking about talking everyone's on
every platform now
talking and having conversations and
talking and talking and i don't want you
guys even to be bludgeoned with that
that's why we don't do more interviews a
week you know we do the
we do these five direct messages and
then i do one max two interviews a week
because i want you guys to live and go
and build and create and all of those
things
and there's so many podcasts now and
everyone's just listening to everyone
talk
i'm interested in people who do who are
fighting things who are actually making
a difference and and the book is going
to be
very much sort of pointed in that
direction what can you now
do in this whacked out world to make a
better life for yourself so
i'll leave it at that for now uh cecito
two says do you think rick grinnell will
run for governor of california
so we just taped it yesterday our friday
panel for tomorrow usually we tried to
do them live but there were some
scheduling issues
and we're doing a panel all about
california tomorrow we've got rick
grinnell who is obviously our former
ambassador to germany and acting
director of intelligence for a little
while in the trump administration
we've got comedian and podcaster adam
carolla
and alicia krauss from the daily wire
and the washington examiner
and i don't want to say anything yet
but somebody on the panel out of those
three people
actually kinda says that it's very
possible that they're gonna run for
california once we recall gavin newsom
which by the way
as of this morning the recall now has
over 1.8
million signatures they only needed one
1.5
to trigger it in the first place but you
know they're gonna in this ridiculous
one-party state we know they're going to
pull all sorts of tricks so i'd love to
see that get over
two million um i will add one other
thing about generally the california
florida thing and everything else
my feeling is for me personally as
whacked out as this state is
and i'm actually going out to dinner
tonight for the first time in a year no
no sorry
i went out to dinner on my birthday june
26th we went out with a couple friends
that is the only time since lockdown has
began
basically one year ago since i've been
out to dinner in la i've gone out to
dinner
in texas i've gone out to dinner in
florida but we are going out
to dinner tonight i believe wait we're
not sitting indoors because you can't
you can't sit indoors right so
i will be eating outdoors okay i will
report back to you maybe i'll even post
a picture
of a of a dinner tonight what a world um
but
as for my future because there's always
a lot of questions about that my feeling
is if if i can be part of recalling
gavin newsom and then we actually you
know once you recall the guy he can
still run again so he'll run again
he could win again in which case nothing
really was accomplished a lot of money a
lot of wasted time and everything else
but if we can recall the guy and then
get in someone better maybe that does
start the dominoes and you know andrew
cuomo in new york is in a lot of hot
water right now because of what he did
putting the old people back in the homes
and everything else and it's like if we
could get rid of
gavin newsom maybe cuomo the pressure
becomes too much and he steps down the
media is kind of turning on him now
they don't need him anymore he was a
real anti-trump surrogate but now they
kind of don't need him since trump's not
there so all these guys are getting
their just desserts i would say
um but if i can have something to do
with that
and fixing california that would be
awesome and then then i could see a path
to staying here longer
um but if it doesn't happen then then
i'm out then i'm out one way or another
uh despite what i said about the
surrogacy stuff which we'd still have to
deal with out of that
um nick says did you do anything new and
exciting
while in florida new and exciting i mean
well mostly i sat on the beach
and uh and i got some sun and i ate a
lot of fish i ate a lot a lot of grouper
a lot of red snapper tried to eat fish
pretty much
every day took a lot of bike rides to
bike ride every morning
did a little bit of reading did i do
anything new and exciting well i ate at
restaurants that was very new and
exciting and i
i talked to people i mean really i you
know a certain amount of people just
recognize me and come up to me even if
i'm
on the beach or at a restaurant but just
we i think i mentioned this the other
day we were at a
at a bar on our last night we're sitting
at this like c-shaped
bar and it turned out that it was a
whole bunch of people from other states
and then a couple floridians there
and we all just started talking like
just talking to strangers and then the
two bartenders got involved in it too
and there were a couple people kind of
sitting around the bar
and we had a group of i'd say about 25
people
kind of all in one conversation about
what it's like some people lived in
minnesota some lived in
chicago as i said some lived in florida
some were in new york some came from
california and all just talking about
what our different frustrations were
and it was clear we didn't all agree on
everything politically and some were old
and some were
gay and some were black and some were
white and guess what nobody punched
anybody it was it was just fine so just
experiencing that
i know that doesn't sound that new and
exciting but in a way
what's old is new again and i think
communicating with human beings in real
life
is actually exciting these days uh kevin
asks music wise uh who or what are you
listening to these days so i busted out
my spotify right before we started
uh because i wanted to give you a true
honest assessment of what i've been
listening to so you guys know if i'm
if i'm doing music with words i'm old
school i like frank sinatra
i like frankie valli i like the supremes
i like a lot of 50s 60s stuff stuff like
that
the great crooners i love all of that i
like i love doo-wop actually i like a
lot of jazz
um but what i really listen to mostly
throughout the day and what we usually
have
going on in the background my crew is
working and just evening and that kind
of thing
i like like sort of ambient um chill
stuff so there is a spectacular channel
on uh spotify that i've been listening
to all the time
it's called uh it's called ambient
electronica
if you can see that right there ambient
electronica
there's no words and look as a guy that
talks for a living and listens to people
talk for a living it's why i kind of
don't like
words all the time so i like the the
crooners and that's kind of stuff
usually for dinners but if just during
the day we usually have music playing
throughout the house i just like that
ambient chill stuff so check out
the ambient electronica channel on
spotify and let me know what you think
um ask 182 says i give you a lot of
credit for having guests on your show
who opposed gay marriage does it ever
bother you that someone looks at your
marriage as wrong
um does it bother me that they look at
it as wrong well
i would first say that everyone's
entitled to their own beliefs and as
long as you're not trying to legislate
my beliefs
then i don't care so if let's put it
this way if gay marriage was not legal
now right so if you were saying well two
consenting adults who happen to be gay
are not allowed to get
into a legal contract that a straight
couple could get into
well then you would not have equality
under the law in my
estimation and by the way in the supreme
court's estimation as well right
and so i would have a problem i would
have a problem but because gay marriage
is the law of the land
it makes it i would say easier to accept
that people have different religious
views which by the way were the
mainstream accepted views for thousands
of years whether you like them or not
so at the end of the day is ben shapiro
allowed to have his
private religious belief from an
orthodox jewish perspective or
bishop robert baron who i've had on the
show who's a catholic bishop
is he allowed to have his personal
religious belief of course the answer is
yes and can i talk to them
about all sorts of things well i can
talk to them about all sorts of things
so
does it bother me like would i would i
ultimately
hope that they would come to my line of
thinking on this sure but do i expect to
sit down with a bishop
and have him rip off the frock and be
like yeah i'm for gay marriage like
no i don't but i think there's other
ways you can build bridges
um and it's sort of funny because you
know when i have some of those people on
i get all the lefties
uh tweeting at me saying that i'm i'm
self-hating and these people hate me and
all that and it's like well not only do
i not get hate from those guys i get
tolerance
but i'm not self-hating and it's like
for the
i thought you guys are the tolerant ones
but you're telling me he's a bigot and
i'm self-hating
as we're talking about tolerance right
and we're talking about agreeing to
disagree
so there you go with that uh eileen says
will you be doing a movie night anytime
soon you know we've done a couple of
these movie nights
uh in the reuben report community
reubenreport.locals.com
where we all watch the same movie at the
same time we get into a netflix party
which is where we can all actually i i
can control the movie so everyone gets
up netflix i click play on it you start
seeing it on your own tv obviously and
then we have a chat throughout the movie
a text
chat throughout the movie and then we do
a giant zoom after and we had
we literally had hundreds of people in
it we have to upgrade our our zoom
things so we can do it with an
unlimited amount of people we did v for
vendetta
uh about was about a month ago or so
maybe a little bit longer that
it's such a freaking phenomenal movie
that will send
send chills up your spine relative to
what's happening in the world right now
the irony is that in the movie the sort
of
fascist controlling thought-controlling
censored
uh group is is of course the people on
the right because that's what
hollywood's gonna give you even though
we're getting it from the people on the
left
these days anyway yes we will do one
soon oh and i will be announcing a live
la meetup next week uh i'll probably
announce it i think i'm gonna announce
it tomorrow
in our locals community it's not going
to be posted publicly anywhere
uh so if you would like to join us and
have a beer
with me live in crazy los angeles
at a location that i met the owner at a
uh at a protest he was he's a great guy
didn't know him
he was at one of the protests when i
went when they uh we protested at this
woman sheila cool's house
she was the deciding vote in the 3-2
vote to close down outdoor uh
restaurants she's the one that literally
had the deciding vote and then went to
eat outdoors
till the because the order didn't kick
in right then it was going to kick in
the next day or so
so she thought outdoor reading was such
a threat that she voted to close out her
eating and then went
to eat outdoors in santa monica a
ridiculous human being as most of these
people are
anyway i met a ton of restaurateurs
there including this guy who owns a
whole bunch of restaurants in la
uh he's had to lay off over a thousand
people uh he he said he was actually
going to run
in some local la election so the re it
will be at his restaurant i will gladly
uh pay for plenty of drinks for plenty
of people so we'll announce that at
ruben report.com
oh sorry rubenreport.locals.com tomorrow
and then we're going to do it one night
next week uh
rebarn says how do you keep your sense
of humor in an increasingly humorous
society well one thing that's been nice
is i think i've been a little funnier
and a little lighter on this show over
the last couple weeks
than i was maybe before the election um
how do you do it i don't know
my default position actually in life
is sort of lighter and funnier i don't
take things that seriously like i know
we are in this massive
fight like i think we are in an
existential fight for for the west
for ourselves for humanity like i really
do
um but i also need to be funny
throughout that i need to i like being
around funny people and light people
ironically i don't love being around
comedians because i usually find
comedians to be pretty depressive and
when i was
when i was i talked a little bit about
this on jack murphy's podcast
a day or two ago when i was doing
stand-up which i did for 12 years in new
york like it comes with a lot of pain
and
you see why so many comedians or
alcoholics or drug addicts or
all this other stuff and as my life kind
of got better i didn't need comedy as
much so one of the funny
the fun things for me has been over the
last couple years as i've gained
popularity because of this
i can sell out these comedy clubs and
i've sold out every club that i've done
in the last couple of years i did a ton
of them
on like an off night when i was on tour
with uh with jp with jordan peterson
and and i have fun up there like it's
not traditional stand up like what's the
deal with the
it's it's more just like it's it's like
a show like i get up there i interact
with you guys and we
talk about what's going on in the world
and it's just like yeah it's fun
so i hope to get back to that we'll
probably have to start in florida uh
because it ain't gonna happen here uh
sarah says what's your favorite place
that you've ever traveled
to and why you know the second year i've
done the off
the grid august thing for four years the
second year that we did it
we did like a week in bora bora
which is french polynesia the french
have somehow taken over polynesia
uh i guess they took it over a long time
ago um and this is if you don't know
what bora bora is i mean just google it
it's when you see those huts that are
just
out over the water and there's fish and
sharks under you
and just that perfect you know you look
out your window and you just see
infinity that's what it feels like
it it feels like you're just seeing the
end of the earth
and it's quiet and it's pleasant and the
beaches are perfect and the food is
great
and and it costs a lot of money so you
got to save up to do it
um and it's it's sort of like a once in
a lifetime kind of thing
but just to sit at the end of the world
and it's quiet and by the way everyone
that goes to these places they're
usually on their honeymoons
so it's like all anyone wants to do
basically is eat and have sex
and then not talk to anybody so it's
just very very
it's very very pleasant i couldn't more
highly recommend it
lauren says would you and david janet
ever host a cooking show clyde can be
the taste tester i posted some of david
janet's uh cooking last night on the
community
uh because he made his cast iron chicken
parm
you can check out david's instagram
actually is instagram.com david's
cookbook he's an incredible chef
we are working on a cookbook he's
working on a cookbook i don't know if
he's going to be happy that i announced
that because that's going to put the
pressure on
and we're trying to see if should i have
some involvement
with it but we have also done dinner
nights in the reuben report community
where we've all
david posts a recipe and then we all
cook something together so maybe we'll
do like a dinner and a movie thing
over the next couple weeks uh free
europe girl says share a funny story
about ben shapiro i love him but he's
always so serious we need to know some
funny stuff
well i feel like i can give you the most
sort of like ben shapiro ben shapiro
story there is
which is when i was on tour with jp the
the last stop that we did in the united
states
was the second show we did in l.a so the
tour kicked off in la
and for those of you that read the book
you know the story that i had ben and
jordan
in my studio in my old house in the
garage
we did like a two or three hour show
together it was phenomenal i think it's
one of the best shows that i've ever
done i think it's the most viewed
episode of the reuben report ever
actually
but i cut it short even though i know
they could have kept continuing because
jordan had this
this theater show that night and he had
never done it before right and remember
jordan
you know even though you think of him
now as as this incredible
uh orator and and uh and author and and
world-renowned
um intellect and traveler and all of
these things and you see him in front of
all these crowds like at that time he
still wasn't quite that
and he had this big show he had this big
show coming up
right that night and it was a test
basically to see if oh could
could this thing tour maybe anyway the
we shut down early because it wasn't
early it was after two or three hours
but we shut down
and as jordan was walking out of my
house i said hey if you want me to come
tonight and warm up the crowd just get
him laughing about lobsters or something
before the show starts let me know
and he's like yeah he didn't even pause
he was just like yeah let's do it
anyway went i crushed it that night the
agents were there they said we're going
to tour this thing and then literally my
life changed
anyway i flash forward like a year and a
half later after 120 stops and 20
countries and all this stuff we were
doing our last
u.s show at the same exact theater
downtown uh la the orpheum theater and
you guys may remember that there was
this whole fracas because
this sort of gets us to an earlier
question ben shapiro said that he
wouldn't bake me a gay
wedding cake not that i would want ben
to bake me a gay wedding cake
not that i think ben is a baker i also
probably wouldn't want a kosher cake
might want something a little a little
more buttery i don't know um
but people were very upset and that made
ben uh homophobe and it made me
a self-hating gay something like that so
we're doing our last show in l.a
and i said ben why don't you come
tonight and i will surprise the crowd
bring you up there and let's just see
what happens
so that night i wore a full-on suit
black suit tie i normally would just
dress up like i normally do i was like
it's our last show in la this is the big
one
i dressed up real sharp ben in typical
ben form he's like working work and
working all day daily wire
shows up like a minute like it's just
like the way he talks fast
like just appears right before we're
about to get on stage
i go up there they announced me the
crowd goes bananas it was so electric
that night it was such an absolutely
special night i think we have some video
of it that maybe i'll
i'll try to play next week for you guys
um
anyway i do about 10 15 minutes the
crowd's rocking it's just electric
and then i'm like and here's special
guest ben shapiro ben walks on stage he
brings me a little cupcake
a little cupcake crowd just freaking
gets it
loves it of course he gets tweeted out
the videos and everything and then you
got all the
the tolerant people uh you know saying
all kinds of awful things about us
ben then did a really funny jordan
impression talks jordan style really
fast
made a couple other jokes walks out and
just goes home and disappears like
and i just thought he was just like the
perfect ben's story because he's busy
but he shows up he does the thing makes
the joke boom and he's out of there
and that's it and it was just such a it
was such an absolutely
absolutely great night and actually i
don't know if you guys can quite see it
can they see that photo
can you grab that photo for me right
there let me grab that for a second
uh my favorite picture of the entire
tour
you know we had as i said we stopped in
so many places and so many
pictures of us on stage and offstage and
everything else there's more about jp
um but this let's see i think you can
see it there right i'm not getting too
glarey
uh we went to dinner that night at uh at
a steak joint with the
with the entire crew and jordan's doing
his uh his whiskey
and i think i was doing some wine and we
had all the agents there and
some fans joined us and it was just just
an absolutely great night
by the way guys speaking of uh jordan i
just did
a two-hour interview with jordan uh
obviously we've connected a bit over the
last
two years but it was just freaking
amazing
to sit down with the guy connect at the
human level talk about his new book and
all that
we are going to be releasing it on
monday right we're doing the whole thing
on monday now this is going to be the
first interview
that will be released related to his
book they're giving us the first one
so the book comes out on march 2nd
beyond order comes out on march 2nd
there's going to be a gajillion
interviews a gajillion people he's doing
the whole press thing although i did
tell him you know just take it easy take
it easy as you're getting back into the
flow
but we are getting the first one the
first one that will be released
will be march 1st this monday two hours
with jp we get personal
uh we reminisce obviously a lot about
the book and it was just so great to
connect with him and you know if there's
any chance
that we get some order back in the world
out of this chaos i think that's the guy
that can bring it to us so hopefully
hopefully he'll continue to heal
continue to get better and we'll get
more jp
uh by the way guys interview my
interview with stephen crowder part two
he's in the middle of a massive lawsuit
with facebook right now twitter banned
him the other day like a lot of
craziness happening around crowder
but he's doing good work uh part two is
up right now
on the youtube and of course the full
episode is already up ad free
at reubenreport.locals.com as i said
tomorrow
our recall gavin newsom california
bonanza panel
with rick grinnell adam carolla and
alicia krauss
is up uh will be up tomorrow at 11 a.m
pacific as always jordan peterson on
monday
and join me at reubenreport.locals.com
for
plenty of other stuff all right that was
a that was a full freaking show have a
good day everybody